Welcome to a history to 10,
the early Middle Ages.
I'm Paul Friedman.
And behind this innocuous title,
the early Middle Ages,
I think we're going to have to jazz it up a little.
I think we're going to put an exclamation mark on it at least.
But behind this innocuous title,
you will see,
I hope,
uh,
if you stay for this course,
a strange course,
strange,
uh,
not because it covers the particular period to 50 to 1000,
but because it starts out very recognizable and get stranger and stranger and
seems to dissolve into a kind of a hard to grasp world,
um,
hard to grasp.
But Fun.
I will talk about both the strangeness and the Fun Aspects,
uh,
in more detail.
There are several great themes in this span of centuries.
The fall of the Roman Empire.
It's survival in the east as the Byzantine Empire,
the so called barbarian invasions and kingdoms set up on the ruins of the Roman
Empire,
the triumph of Christianity,
which went from being an outlawed minority religion to the established faith of
the Roman Empire,
and then survive to the extinction of the Roman empire.
Uh,
we have,
uh,
two teaching fellows,
Lauren Mann,
Sia sitting at this end and on Yessica rats standing in that corner
so far.
Their section scheduled for Wednesday at four o'clock and Friday at 10 30.
Uh,
we'll probably have two other sections.
we'll see how large the class is next week.
Let me know if those two section times,
uh,
well probably the classes,
the sections to be added would be on Thursday,
Thursday afternoon and Thursday evening.
But let me know if you have some special problem in terms of the scheduling of
your,
uh,
of the sections.
Uh,
as I said,
um,
when,
when some of you were already here,
I'll have some pauses so that if you are shopping and want to look at another
course,
uh,
it'll be,
if not easy,
at least possible for you to get up and leave.
Um,
so I'll have several pauses during the,
uh,
during the,
presentation.
But I should say I do want to give a full class,
um,
a discussion today or presentation today.
We only have so many opportunities to discuss things.
And I'd like to set the scene for you and I think that will also help you
decide,
uh,
um,
about taking this course.
Now,
this course is part of the a Yale open courses a program.
Uh,
and as you probably know,
there are lots of,
uh,
well a select number,
but a substantial number of courses that are offered free to the public via the
Internet.
And this is one of them for the fall.
And I take this opportunity to greet our,
uh,
Internet students and Internet,
um,
uh,
friends.
So since it's part of this project,
uh,
a Yale University broadcast team,
will be,
uh,
recording all the classes and,
um,
there'll be as unobtrusive as possible.
The classroom experience will be essentially as it would be if they're not there
and it's their intention to videotape me and not you.
Uh,
uh,
so neither your faces nor voice.
Uh,
our voices are supposed to appear.
You're questions are unlikely to be a herd.
I will repeat the questions so that people watching this,
uh,
on the Internet will have an idea.
And I do encourage questions,
both things that you haven't understood or things for elucidation.
I have a slightly more formal lecture style then some people perhaps,
um,
uh,
I have,
try to have a reasonably structured,
uh,
lecture that doesn't wander off too much.
Some of you have taken courses from me and know that,
uh,
I have certain themes or preoccupations or a diversions,
but I'm going to try to,
uh,
be as coherent as possible,
partly because we are,
um,
uh,
filming this.
Um,
so I hope that you're enthusiastic about the fact that a,
we're participating in this,
uh,
Yale open courses initiative.
And having said that now you should just think it away.
Um,
uh,
the,
the team is broadcast team is not very conspicuous and the objective is for us
to interact in the classroom as we normally would.
And,
um,
uh,
this is part of the unique experience of teaching and learning at Yale.
So don't hesitate to ask me if you have any questions or concerns.
Uh,
the syllabus,
you all have copies a of the syllabus I believe.
And of course you'll have seen it on the server.
Uh,
the books are at Yale Bookstore and they are all there.
I'm,
I hope there will be enough copies.
If not,
we will,
we will get more.
The first assignment is a,
um,
conveniently in this sense from the course pack.
The course pack is at Tyco,
the photocopy place on Elm Street.
Uh,
if you don't know where is,
uh,
um,
let us know.
Um,
and the assignments for Monday and Wednesday,
uh,
from the,
um,
uh,
the f those first two assignments are from that book from Peter Brown's world of
late antiquity and h m Jones a Constantine.
I'm the conversion of western Europe
questions so far.
Right.
Okay.
So,
uh,
the requirements that you'll see on the syllabus or a short paper that's due
October the 10th
a midterm that will be held in class October 17th and the long paper,
which is due December 5th,
that long paper is a research paper.
And we'll be glad to help you choose a topic,
offer you suggestions,
help you get started on that.
It's 15 to 20 pages and accounts for 40% of your grade.
Here's a midterm counts,
30% of the grade,
the short paper,
20% and your section grade is 10%.
Now,
this course does not have honorous requirements,
but I expect you to do the requirements that we have.
There's no final exam.
I urge you to blot out of your mind the temptation not to do the reading because
there's no final exam or the reading of the second part of the course.
And if we think that this is a problem,
judging on the basis of how the sections go,
we reserve the possibility of giving you quizzes in the section and the section
half of the course,
a paper times,
uh,
we're going to be firm on this.
I can't say absolutely no extensions on the paper because I acknowledged the
existence of overwhelming emergencies.
But let me give you an example of an excuse that's not going to be accepted.
I have three other papers due that week.
Okay.
Plan in advance.
We are at your disposal.
If you want to plan your final paper tomorrow,
Hey,
this afternoon,
uh,
talk to me how I'm eager to,
to hear from you about that.
Uh,
in the sections.
we don't want you to bring laptops and the reason for that is not that we think
you're going to be,
um,
Facebooking or answering your email because we know that you never do that.
Um,
uh,
the laptops in our experience interfere with the purpose of the section,
which is partly to talk to each other and rather than focusing on the screen and
then in a sense being a series of archipelago of little islands rather than a
section in the sense of give and take and uh,
interchange.
If you think that that imposes some kind of hardship on you,
I think you'll find,
uh,
that uh,
it is pleasant.
And if there's some technical hardship,
let me know.
Okay.
So logistical questions
Pushkin's about the organization of the course or a,
any other aspect of this?
Good.
That means that I'm a clearer then,
uh,
on some occasions.
So,
uh,
if anybody is,
wants to leave,
now this is one opportunity,
but since it looks like I have your attention riveted,
uh,
let me introduce the course in terms of its actual content.
We are beginning by looking at the crisis of the Roman empire and then we will
be looking at it's peculiar legacy in the year 1000 where we stopped,
we will still be dealing with the inheritance of the Roman empire.
The title of Chris Wickham's book,
one of the books that we're going to be using a lot.
The legacy is peculiar because while the memory of the Roman empire remains
intact throughout the period and beyond,
I mean,
to this day,
the head of the Catholic church is in Rome,
uh,
until 1960 the year,
transactions of the papacy were in Latin.
The services of the church.
We're in line with the Catholic church.
We're in Latin and Latin remains the official language of,
uh,
of the Catholic church in its administrative head.
So,
um,
the most faithful preserver of Rome and its legacy historically is the Catholic
church.
And this is a paradox because the church begins it's career and indeed its first
250 years as illegal in the Roman empire.
And indeed there are periodic persecutions where people were punished,
including,
uh,
killed because they were Christians.
The most faithful preserver of Rome.
However,
after the fifth century collapse of the empire in the West is the so called
Byzantine Empire,
the Byzantine Empire
with its headquarters in Constantinople.
Okay.
Despite the fact that it would abandoned Latin for Greek in the sixth century
and turn into a very different kind of political and cultural entity,
the Byzantine Empire went down in flames to the Turks in 15,
14,
53,
uh,
still as the Roman empire.
That was its official name to the end.
Another air to the Roman empire in a sense is Islam,
which begins in the seventh century,
in the middle of our period.
I don't have to emphasize to you the historical importance of Islam,
but our task is to understand its origin and its astonishing expansion in terms
of this era to 50 to 1000 to understand it in terms of its times and thus how it
arises and interacts with,
uh,
the Roman and Byzantine as well as offstage the Persian empires that it either
destroys or weekends.
In the seventh and eighth centuries,
Muhammad was from outside the former empire from Arabia and maybe said to
represent a very different kind of set of ideas.
Okay.
But the power of Islam would for centuries be concentrated in areas of the
former Roman empire,
the Mediterranean,
the Balkans,
Egypt,
Syria,
North Africa.
Of course in the the ladder,
it's a,
still is one of the overwhelming majority religion.
And Islam then brings up a sort of,
um,
question that I'm not going to deal with directly very much,
but that will be at the back of our minds.
And that is relevance.
Uh,
this is a preindustrial course.
It's in the very preindustrial category in terms of requirements.
Uh,
it's far away.
It's distant.
That is part of its appeal I think is it's as I said,
its strangeness.
Um,
but the lessons from the material covered in this course are perhaps these,
we're thinking about
how perhaps the most successful multicultural empire of Western history,
how it did that,
how it endured for so long,
the success of the Roman empire and wide finally failed.
And in that failure,
how does a rich literate,
well-developed society come to be destroyed by a more primitive one primitive,
at least in the sense of material culture,
economic complexity,
urbanization and literacy.
Okay.
Another important lesson is the power of religious ideas,
not only intrinsically as part of people's lives and outlook,
but socially and historically how religion affects the political course of
history.
Having said this,
I think I did mention,
I was going to tell you what was fun about this course.
This is what I think is fun and I've already kind of alluded to this.
We begin with a familiar world in the sense that the Roman Empire,
although obviously not technologically the same as the one we live in,
is a very advanced society and a very complex one.
Advanced,
you know,
go to Europe and look around and see the engineering feats of the Romans.
See the public life that the Babs stadia temples,
law courts,
marketplaces,
uhh,
who's ruins still,
uh,
in many instances,
dwarf the towns that survived around them.
See how,
what an accomplishment that is.
It is a huge empire of bureaucratic empire.
One with lots of literate people,
a huge army,
a huge civil service,
a lot of commerce back and forth,
all things that are familiar to us.
But as it weakens and collapses,
you get a kind of,
if not post apocalyptic,
at least transformative experience.
It gets stranger and stranger more and more disorganized,
harder to understand at first grasp.
Basically we begin in the Shire and we end up in more dangerous territories.
It's hard to describe the territory that we end up in,
but that is what I think is intriguing about the course.
You,
you,
you start out in a familiar world and it just becomes something alien.
But I think appealing,
appealing.
But I do have one morning for you or one,
um,
thing that I have seen students surprised at and sometimes even annoyed at and
that is we've got to talk about religion,
uh,
both Christianity and Islam.
Uh,
and uh,
to a more limited extent Judaism this and also paganism for that matter.
But the one that tends to bother people actually is Christianity.
So,
you know,
sometimes people will say,
oh,
I thought I was taking a history course and it's turned into a religious studies
course before my eyes.
We're going to have to talk about some heresies.
You're going to have to understand actually what,
uh,
what people are fighting and killing each other over when they talk about the
nature of Christ or the relationship among the three persons of the trinity.
Um,
this is unfamiliar.
Uh,
but again,
I think unfamiliarity is for us and unfamiliarity has a funny way of turning
into familiar.
When I started teaching,
well,
dinosaurs weren't walking the earth,
but they just departed.
Um,
primitive birds,
early mammals.
Um,
the assumption was that religion was safely,
uh,
you know,
religion is a political movement.
Not Religion is a personal
commitment,
but religion as something that had an impact on politics was pretty safely gone.
And that was a feature of medieval history.
Obviously,
the last,
uh,
um,
years have shown us in many ways to the power of religious ideas,
the power of religious ideas not know,
uh,
solely personally,
but collectively not solely as sentiments,
but as political movements.
So we begin with the crisis of the empire,
the first crisis of the empire in the third century,
a day.
If we go back just before that,
I mean,
this is an officially part of the course.
This is like,
you know,
the chef offers you this little,
uh,
I'm used Bruce this little a snack to begin the mail,
the period of the good emperors,
the second century I do.
The good emperor is a term a popularized by the great historian of the decline
and fall of the Roman empire,
Edward Gibbon,
who wrote in the 18th century.
And it's one of those works that whatever it's myriad factual and interpretive
and accuracies still sets the program for how we look at the decadence and
collapse of the Roman Empire.
Gibbon says,
if a man were called upon to fix the period in history of the world during which
the condition of the human race was most happy and prosperous,
he would without hesitation name that which lapsed from the excession of Nerva
to the death of Marcus or yes,
that is 96 to one 80 a day.
He goes on there.
United rains are possibly the only period in which the happiness of a great
people was the sole object of government.
So it's this period of the so called good emperors against which the subsequent
decline traced in Gibbons monumental work,
uh,
would take place.
Okay.
Now,
as opposed to given we're not so confident that the Roman empire was so
wonderful for everybody involved,
we have a somewhat more egalitarian outlook than Gibbons.
Gibbons never says,
oh,
well what about the slaves?
Or,
oh,
hey,
what about the peasant?
Or,
Hey,
the position of,
uh,
women in society.
Um,
but more than that,
I think we have some more doubt and hesitation as to whether any state,
particularly any powerful state,
um,
necessarily represents a,
of virtue or happiness for the poor.
The smooth functioning of the Roman government was less important than it was
for the property classes because the Roman state,
like most states in so far is it practice.
The rule of law,
uh,
was set up to guarantee property,
not rights.
And you'll see Wickham when we come to read him.
He emphasizes in the chapter on the burden of rule and the Roman Empire.
Uh,
this September 19th,
the Roman empire was not organized to reward ordinary people
to different degrees.
And at varying times it did rely on slave labor.
This is easy to exaggerate.
It's not a slave society.
Uh,
it's not an overwhelmingly slave owning society,
but certainly,
uh,
it,
um,
uh,
many of its enterprises involved slavering it's laws were designed to protect
the property of the wealthy rather than to mete out equal justice.
Rome was an imperial power.
And as I will say in a moment,
it was an extraordinarily tolerant one,
but it was tolerant as long as you conform to their image of civilization.
Like many great imperial powers,
it assumed that there were certain areas of life that were optional.
They were very tolerant with regard to religion,
for example.
But their definition of civilization was being like us.
They were generous about that.
They would make citizens of people from the Celtic lands of Britain,
uh,
to Egypt.
But this meant conforming to a certain set of standards,
beliefs,
assumptions,
and way of life.
Another thing that,
um,
we now would descent from,
given about is the efficiency of the Roman Empire to given in the 18th century,
the Roman Empire appeared a marvel of efficiency,
but really how could it be efficient?
The distances were so long and travel was so slow.
This is an empire that took weeks and weeks to traverse in the state of
communications.
And we know from Contemporary Times that even with great communications need
with instantaneous communications.
It's very hard to hold states together.
And in fact,
one of the things that's happened in the last 50 years is the weakening of the
state,
strangely enough,
strangely,
because what people thought was going to happen is what had been going on in the
20th century.
Generally,
states have become more and more powerful,
more and more dictatorial,
more and more.
Um,
uh,
tyrannical and indeed George Orwell's 1984 written in the post war era in the
late 1940.
[inaudible] assumes that totalitarianism is what's going to be generalized.
In fact,
it turns out that the problem is not so much the state.
Look at the great states of the mid 20th century,
you know,
one no longer exists,
the Soviet Union and the other,
the United States,
uh,
you know,
whatever our strengths are,
it doesn't seem to be the extraordinary power of the central government,
which is in fact much reduced from what it was in Saint 1950.
Uh,
by,
uh,
any measurement.
So we have a different idea of the state.
We're more aware of the limitations of state power in press times.
We're more aware of the discrepancy between the rhetoric of power.
And that no,
a polity equals the Roman empire for it's ceremonies of power.
It's architecture of power,
it's culture of power,
um,
but the emperor in fact,
however glorious,
however much in the third century,
was worshiped as a god.
A,
his power was limited.
His power was limited in terms of enforcement,
if not in theory,
and this will be important because right from the start we're going to assess
the accomplishments of the emperor Diocletian at the end of the third century
and the Emperor Constantine,
beginning of the forts threat who may be said to have saved the empire from
collapse.
The thing about the Roman Empire that is indisputable and does not have a value
judgment attached to it is that it was enduring.
The Roman empire lasted for an incredibly long time.
It was stable
in a year for 10,
the Visigoths sacked plundered a Rome.
I entered the city of Rome's so called barbarian tribe and they pitched it.
They pillaged it in a fairly orderly way,
but nevertheless they pillaged it.
This was the first time this had happened in the city of Rome in something on
the order of 800 years.
The empire itself by this time was nearly 400 years old.
The other indisputable accomplishment of the Roman Empire is that it controlled
the Mediterranean.
The Mediterranean was its center referred to often as Maray no strong as our
Si,
our c because they controlled all of the shoreline of the Mediterranean.
The only power that has ever done that
there have been great empires.
The Ottoman Empire,
the Byzantine Empire,
the caliphate,
but none of them controlled more than,
uh,
um,
about 40% of the Mediterranean at any one time.
So even if we dissent from Gibbons calm assurance that the best period of human
history was the era of the good emperors in the second century,
a d we shouldn't minimize the accomplishments of this empire and of this era to
live in security with respect to both outside enemies and ex internal disorder
essentially piece.
And the rule of law,
uh,
was unusual.
And unfortunately it remains so.
Rome was an immense empire,
stretched from England to the Sahara from Spain to Armenia.
It had a common language of administration,
Latin and two cultural languages.
Greek and Latin understood by the elite from one end of the empire to the other.
The cities were not walled until the third century
given in particular emphasizes the tolerance of Rome,
which appealed to his innate anticlerical at some.
And as many of you know,
his explanation for the fall of the empire was Christianity.
It was Christianity that weekend.
The empire weakened.
It's elite,
turns its attention to foolish controversies over trinitarian or Christological
concerns when they should have been concentrating on the barbarians.
But this is not,
uh,
accepted any more,
for reasons that will become clearer in these first few weeks.
And,
um,
it's appeal though the idea of toleration is very important to give and writing
in the 18th century when Europe had just emerged from centuries of religious
wars,
having seen the wars of the reformation,
well not literally,
he hadn't lived through them,
but being the inheritor of these religious wars of the 30 years' war in Germany
in the 17th century of religious controversy in Britain,
a gibbon,
like many members of the enlightenment generation,
he was part of a thought that the world would be far better if religion remain
either a exclusively private matter or just disappeared.
So for him,
the villain in history,
and in particular the villain in Roman history is religion.
But however tolerant of course,
uh,
roam drew the line at Christianity
for reasons we shall discuss.
But it is still historically quite unusual.
The empire should have permitted all of these other religions.
Indeed.
Rather than re guarding,
say the religions of Egypt as inferior,
they simply brought those gods in Monday.
You might worshiped Zeus and Tuesday,
Hey,
if you want it to,
uh,
you know,
see if isis was,
they're going to help you,
uh,
with your,
um,
uh,
impending business deal.
Why not go and see a,
um,
uh,
an Egyptian temple?
So it's a collectors a little bit like the way Americans dine out,
you know,
uh,
it makes no sense to most people in most of the world to say something like,
Oh,
I don't want Japanese food.
I had that for lunch.
No,
I mean,
if you're in Japan,
you are expected of Japanese food for lunch and for dinner.
And same with Italian food.
The same is true of religion.
Most people don't just say,
oh,
I don't want to go to a Presbyterian church this weekend.
Go,
go well worship at a Buddhist temple.
Just,
uh,
just,
for change.
Um,
this is more in the nature of Roman religion.
So this kind of tolerance is unusual.
Uh,
so tolerance,
tolerance is a real virtue of the empire,
even if it's limited real virtue because it's,
it's,
it's unusual historically.
Um,
piece,
the Roman Empire spent half of its state budget on the army.
On the other hand,
no empire.
This large could be held together by military means alone.
It was held together by any elite that shared notions of civilization that made
certain sacrifices for the public good.
Those games,
uh,
the,
circuses,
the competitions,
uh,
the ceremonies where usually paid for by private people,
not by the state for example.
Okay.
It is an urban civilization with an elite that is urban.
The cities
held their local gods.
They had local administration,
they built aqueducts,
temples,
law courts,
all these edifices that I mentioned earlier.
Um,
it was a cosmopolitan way of life.
So it's diverse in the sense that there are many different peoples,
but unified in the sense that the elite shares a common language.
And even the city planning is the same.
If you went to London or you went to Tim,
God in what's now the Algerian desert,
you'd know your way around,
you'd know where to find the marketplace.
You'd know that it was laid out in a grid.
You'd know where the law courts would be in relation to the temples.
You could find joy just as,
you know,
if you get off the interstate,
uh,
but there'll be a,
a,
you know,
a Wendy's or identities or you know,
a shell station.
Uh,
and uh,
yeah,
it would be an exceptional place that didn't have them.
And you know,
if you couldn't find,
uh,
you know,
a home depot even without benefit of technical,
uh,
AIDS getting off an exit of the average interstate highway that,
you know,
you,
you don't live in America or you haven't been here very long.
So it was the same thing.
Um,
there's a sort of a mental picture of what a city looks like from one end of the
empire to the other.
But it is an empire that is centered around the Mediterranean and not just
logistically or politically,
but culturally for the Romans,
their empire included lands where all of trees didn't grow and where in wine
grapes didn't flourish,
but those places were not places they wanted to live.
They wanted to control them.
But,
um,
they were beyond civilizations.
So a government official on the Danube,
uh,
in what's now Hungary writes home complaining that quote,
the inhabitants lead the most miserable of lives for the cultivate.
No olives and they drink no wine.
Ended up story.
And you can imagine there's a certain kind of east coast discourse on the order
of they have blueberry bagels out here.
I can't live here or you know,
little nearest Starbucks is 30 miles away and there's no substitute.
This is an impressive empire that,
and so it's flaws.
Uh,
it has,
um,
an imbalance between the urban and the rural.
Not as great as historians once thought,
but it is dominated by cities but depend on peasants.
But the tend to drain the land of its vitality.
It's also imbalanced east,
west,
strangely enough for an empire that was founded in the west,
by the time we start the east is more prosperous,
it's more urban,
it has more trade,
it's better organized,
more commercial.
Another flaw.
This empire is its size and you know,
it works for a long time and then when it doesn't work,
this becomes a real problem.
And then the army,
the army in the third century discovers that it can make and unmake emperors.
So the immediate crisis of the third century,
which lasts from two 35 to the excession of Diocletian in two 84,
is that it has dozens and dozens of emperors.
Most rain for less than three years,
all but one die violently.
So the two things are linked.
The power of the army to proclaim an emperor and the inability of that emperor
to keep his power before the army or an army somewhere in one province or
another,
uh,
rises up another emperor and kills the former one.
So it's a durable and prior,
but an unwieldy and in certain respects,
exhausted one.
So in the first part of the course,
we're going to look at how this empire function and we're going to look at it's
two great crises.
The first of them,
this third century crisis,
which involves all these many different emperors also has invasions from Persia,
also has the first indications of barbarian invasions across the frontier of the
Danube and the Rhine rivers.
But it survives this first crisis.
And that is the accomplishment of Diocletian about whom you're going to be
reading.
The second crisis that of the fifth century is similar in many respects,
but more final in its results.
The third,
the fifth century crisis witnesses the collapse of the Roman Empire in the West,
the fall of the Roman empire of given that given made famous.
And that continues to inspire a certain amount of fascination and fear today.
So here are some questions that we're should be in the back of your mind at
least a while.
You do this reading for the first few weeks when we're talking about the
collapse or weakening of the Roman Empire.
Did this happen because of foreign threats or internal weakness?
The rhetorical topo center often invoked with regard to empires in the modern
world is internal weakness.
That's because the opponents don't seem very savage or very,
uh,
impressive,
but,
um,
it's not necessarily a given.
Uh,
as I said before,
external enemies,
even the don't impure to be that imposing can,
uh,
under certain circumstances,
um,
impress their will on what would seem to be a more powerful empire to some
extent.
That is indeed because of internal weakness but at won't do to exaggerate that.
But this is one of the,
one of the problems,
another problem is continuity versus change.
The East survives the east even flourishes for awhile and even for a while seems
to be on the verge of reconquering the West from the barbarians.
So how can we talk about the fall of the Roman Empire when,
you know,
only part of it false.
Another question is how did the rise of Christianity affect the political and
cultural fortunes of the empire?
As I said,
Gibbon said it affected its fortunes by you know,
or destroying it.
But beyond that,
I think over simple explanation,
how did Christianity change the empire?
Was this change a catastrophe or a transformation?
And how did Christianity triumph?
It seems to be so alien to everything.
Roman,
how does it become,
uh,
the,
official religion of the empire and how does it become indeed identified with
the empire?
All of these questions are currently very much debated by historians.
I'm not going to have a definitive answer for you.
I have certain opinions.
I'll present the information basically in accord with that.
But,
uh,
um,
this is not something that has been scientifically proven or,
uh,
received universal acknowledgement.
So we begin this course with the reign of the emperor Diocletian to 84 to three
oh five.
And we do this because he solved a number of problems which threatened the
survival of the empire in the third century.
These problems,
as I said,
instability of rule Persian invasion,
barbarian invasions,
and then one I didn't mention,
which is inflation,
tremendous economic dislocation.
All of these are manifestations of the longterm flaws just mentioned.
But the thing about longterm flows,
I mean,
you know,
you can point to longterm flaws in the Soviet empire or longterm falls flaws in
the British empire,
but why do they manifest themselves when they do or to put it in another way?
Why does the empire go on and flourished for a couple of hundred years or a few
decades and then collapse.